.
And we're just about 52 minutes
away from the closing Bell for
the week up in New York and
joining me here in studio
directly across from me is
Chris Wallace. The anchor of
FOX News Sunday you can follow
that show at FOX News Sunday on
twitter check your local
listings on your local FOX
station you can watch replays
on fnc he's also a best-selling
author. His new book
that he has here in studio with
us and if you're watching on
the FOX nation live stream.
You can see the cover of it or
you will when it comes to him
and the title of that book is
countdown bin laden. The
untold story of the 247 day
hunt to bring the mastermind of
9.11 to justice and Chris it is
such a pleasure to see you in
person for the first time
in 18 months or so I was gonna
say a year and
a half I I I I thought I'd
gotten out of jail but now I'm
back with you Saleh countdown
bin laden, how's it just a
totally compelling read
I think it's fair to say the
definitive account of how we
got bin laden. Well thank you
for
it's too crowded. It's the
number 2 Ford the second week
in a row, the number 2 book in
the New York Times bestseller
list.
>> Both hardcover and e-book.
You know, which
is nice. But I'm really proud
of the book and I'm very
pleased by the reception it's
gotten it's a history thriller.
You know you know how it ends
but the people I get a lot of
e-mails from people at 2
o'clock in the morning saying I
couldn't put it down and our
new I just finished it. And you
know that
that the last 100 pages they
were just on the edge of their
seat because they wanted to see
what happened next. There are
surprises. Things that have not
been said before told before
people who haven't talked
before. It's a
good book and you know just as
I'm proud of it countdown bin
laden by Chris Wallace or guest
available for sale right now
Chris I want to play couple
sound bites for you the
president finally Danes to
answer some questions today,
it's been a while.
>> And he was asked about the
border.
This a legit whipping quote
UNQUOTE incident of course came
out and he decided to kind of
lean into it and go nuclear to
a certain extent here is an cut
7.
>> I was hardwood to see you
saw to see people treated like
they did horses really running
over people being strapped.
It's outrageous. I promise you
those people
will pay. They will be the
investigation underway now and
there will be consequences.
There will be consequences.
It's an embarrassment it's
beyond embarrassment. It's
dangerous it's wrong. It sends
the wrong message around the
sends the wrong message at
home. It's simply not who we
are.
>> The vice president kamala
Harris was on the view a bit of
a bumpy start to that show
today will play that audio
later. She echoed this line
cut 19.
>> I've been very clear about
the images that you and I both
saw of those law enforcement
officials on horses I I was
outraged
by it. It was
horrible and deeply troubling
there's been now an
investigation is being
conducted which I fully support
and there needs to be
consequences accountability.
Did human being should not be
treated that way and as we all
know it also evokes images
of some of the worst moments of
our history
where that kind of behavior has
been used against
the indigenous people of our
country has been used against
African Americans during times
of slavery so I'm glad to
to know that that alli Meyer
has the SEC chair of the
Department of homeland security
is taking it very seriously.
>> And moments ago
the aforementioned my orcas was
at the White House at the
podium and talking about
systemic racism and how
horrified he was by all of
this. I feel
like I'm losing my mind
because I've watched the
videos, I've looked at the
images, the photographer who
took the famous photograph has
now come out and said we didn't
see any whipping the photo is
being misconstrued. Border.
Patrol says there was no
whipping there were no wimps
but it has this talking point
is just been willed into
existence that Border Patrol
was out there whipping Haitian
illegal immigrants
and the president is denouncing
it you know from the very
highest level the biggest bully
pulpit in the world. Have you
seen any evidence that people
we're wept.
but I have seen the guy the
Border Patrol using their
horses to intimidate and.
>> Pushback people I
let me go with my big point and
then I'll get to the to the
whipping and in the in the
first place I when I was
hurting the clip of the
president about this is
embarrassing.
>> wrong and it sends the wrong
signal to the world.
I was thinking he really should
be saying that about our
immigration policy and the fact
that 15,000 people came across
this dam in the Del Rio and
then we're had to spend days
more than a week in the squalor
under this bridge.
I mean to me that is the real
shame here is our immigration
policy and that allows people
to come over a dozen just stop
them. And that's what I think
the real focus ought to be on.
Yes,
the horse story that the Border
Patrol cbp
on horseback has become a story
I happen to think it's bad for
get the weapon for a second and
I I understand that's one of
the allegations and their debt
doesn't seem to be true and the
president should have talked
about strapping as he did
because that's another. We've
heard for whipping I don't
think that the
the Border Patrol they want to
be able to find a way to keep a
bull from coming across the
border.
Build a fence, a wall maybe
yeah I was going to Cybill
defense build a wall have some
kind of a gate so they can't
walk across that dam.
Over the Rio
Grande into del Rio. I don't
know that I think the idea of
guys on horseback stopping
migrants from coming by rushing
out the bull rushing them with
the horses forget whether their
webs or not I don't think
that's right and either.
Time that I find that offensive
really I mean Plano police
departments use horses in crowd
control in the United States
again says it's often says this
is a different thing. This is
people coming across the border
illegally. I understand I'm not
saying they should be allowed
to cross the border right, I'm
saying there ought to be a less
offensive way to do it like
putting up barriers or a wall I
that's all I'm side. What I
think the idea and you know I
don't think that you usually
see horses in crowd control
racing running at these The way
that
they were in American cities.
The way they were at the border
with these patients. Yeah, I
think we can get into the
specifics of crowd control and
police tactics in La I happen
to think that missing the point
I do to get and I think it's
actually the goal of the
administration for us to miss
the point rushes the crisis so
let's not focus on the real and
I agree it just I think to me
during the last president.
He was criticized a lot for
making things up and not saying
things that were in alignment
with actual facts and
I think why I'm so bothered
about the whipping stuff even
though I'm taking the bait from
the administration is that it's
just not true they keep
saying it I love that I worry
about the weapon, but I don't
think that that lets these
Border Patrol off the hook
because I think the whole use
of horses was wrong.
Okay, so the point I'm making
but I again I think that word
that we're missing the point
which is the the real problem
here is that it was allowed to
happen because of the
negligence of the Biden border
policy I mean, here's the
problem I have with with
Biden talking about a more
humane policy so they say
we're going to have a more
humane policy we're going and
we're going to roll back remain
in Mexico. And the result of
rolling back remain in Mexico
is that it entice it says to
people trying trying to come
across illegally and illegally
is a big deal
that it's okay to come across
the border and if you have to
wait for months or years in
some cases to have your your
immigration hearing you'll be
able to do it from the comfort
of being in the United States.
I think it actually would be
more humane to say to them no,
don't don't don't come over
don't be humble under the
bridge. Stay in Mexico or don't
come up at
all because I I think this half
door open policy is creating a
lot of problems that that I
stricter policy what and
we have one 0.5 million known
border encounters this fiscal
year and counting so far plus
hundreds of thousands of known
got a ways. What's happening
the policy is failing. The whip
stuff is a sideshow I stopped
what they are upset the policy
is a mess I agree I think
that's why they are happy to
repeat the lie about whipping
is because you and I will sit
here talking I'm not I'm not
talking about the weapon but
the president is the vice
president has We've covered it,
let's move on to the policy and
I think the real problem is the
policy the policy
is wrong and you know I just
watch some of my organs, maybe
this is why I'm spun up about
it because he said that we
inherited a broken system and
we've got to fix it. They're
not fixing it and he talks
about well comprehensive
immigration reform we
all know does not have a
comprehensive immigration for I
agree there should be but there
isn't going to be just as a
matter of political reality so
find measures that you
can use that will alleviate the
system and part of it is as an
American I'm offended at this
open door that's allowing
people to come in 15,000.
What you think somewhere
it turns out that in Del Rio he
said this for the first time
since September 9th they've had
30,000 people come across the
border, wouldn't you think
somewhere between a 100 or a
1030 1000 you've said OK, let's
stop it.
And what they inherited
obviously not a perfect system
by any stretch, but the numbers
weren't anywhere close to this
in the last administration so
just say oh well, you know,
this is a broken process of
what can we do that doesn't
Hackett.
You have anyone from the Biden
White House on FOX News Sunday
this weekend because I saw some
people last weekend saying they
offered no one from the
national security team
after the admission of the
drone strike that killed 7
children.
Are they offering up people
don't You know we have asked
Mister Meir secretary my orcas
and we're interested to see
whether they're going make them
available or not we
do know, we're going to have an
exclusive interview with the
governor of Texas Greg Abbott
so we'll discover a discuss the
issue at length will also have
a report from on the ground at
the border.
And we're hoping to have
somebody from the
administration that we can at
some of these very good
questions about you know the
thing about. I'm not going to
contradict myself about the
weapon. Chris they
won't even that's costs have
been somebody asked what is it
that you think they did wrong
and my orcas wouldn't even say
what they did wrong. I happen
to think the horses was wrong.
The whipping seems to have but
they should at least have an
answer to that when I say
they're horrified treating like
a crime against humanity also
didn't make a in Majorca is the
part of the news conference I
saw as to how many of these
people from del Rio
have actually been released
into the United States to wait
for processing. Yes, they're
supposed to see an immigration
judge but that can as I say
take years.
Over on Capitol Hill just you
know steps from where we sit
right now Democrat leaders are
having a real whale of a time
wrangling votes for a number of
different issues you've got the
reconciliation package you've
got the debt ceiling. You've
got this bipartisan
infrastructure bill they're
putting out statements they're
making noises about progress
but I'm not sure if the
progress is is concrete or
tangible yet how do you see
this playing out or is this
truly fluid. Well it's it's
absolutely fluid. There's no
question about it.
They definitely are not going
have a government shutdown the
Democrats or the controlling
party, the governing party,
they control both houses as
well as the White House there's
not a chance that they're going
to have a government shutdown
on Friday morning. Debt
ceiling. That they're
not going to go into default
somehow that will get settled.
The big question are the
one 0.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill and the
spending bill which is now at 3
and a half trillion. I suspect
it will be last.
You know I it's absolutely
fluid and I only say this
because as a political realist
I don't see how
the Democrats with control
can't come up with a compromise
it may be a lot less than
Bernie Sanders want a lot more
than Joe Manchin much. There's
got to be some number between
one and a half and trillion and
3 and a half trillion which is
where they both are
that they could both hold their
nose and agreed to because it
seems to me you put the
Democrats in charge and they
can't pass their own
president's agenda that
is a catastrophe, I feel a
tickle catastrophe low C feels
like she can't let that happen
and re-use generally pretty
good whipping the votes, a
different kind of weather got
Chris Wylie we've got is that I
feel like you're too young to
get the reference. But I'm sure
some of your listeners were and
Groucho used to be a magic word
and when you said the magic
word Doc would come down with
the magic word
that obviously today its
weapons last question very
briefly, the least important
question you'll get all week.
We had a poll here on the show
and we had Jesse waters weigh
in our Jimmy failla way and
then we posted on on on twitter
as well
of the e-mail correspondence
here at FOX News, the question
is who has the best hair.
It was Peter Doocy was Matt
Finn was allusion allusion one
thousands of
people voted Lucian won by a 17
point margin Chris I have to
ask you to the people get it
right in your mind say it again
it was Peter a login and that
fit in number lowton I I agree
with the low tonight, you know
I to look at the Luton I think
if I had looked like him that
would have been no stopping me
I might
have been success of this very
well you are a success because
you've got to Somebody
and you've got a number 2
best-selling book in the
country down like number one
count down bin laden countdown
bin laden by Chris Wallace my
guest will be watching FOX News
Sunday thi